hey everyone its Warren and we finally
have a confirmation on who Jude Law's
character is and Captain Marvel there
are actually a few confirmations on who
his character is we got them this
morning from Fandango and some promo
leaks
we got Captain Marvel and Avengers
in-game promo leaks if you haven't seen
the Avengers in-game ones I'll put the
link up above and there are only a
handful of days left in my Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway if you would like to
enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero I will be picking the winner
on January 1st so as I said this morning
we got quite a few promo art leaks and a
lego league as well following these
leaks Fandango also tweeted this morning
confirming that Jude Law's character in
Captain Marvel is in fact Marvel as you
can see here for this promo art photo of
Star Force it lists each character's
name above their heads and as you can
see right above Jude Law's head is
Marvel confirming that he will in fact
be Marvel it also seems like Carol
Danvers will have a nickname on Star
Force as you can see right above her
head it says vers which is obviously
short for danvers we then got a Lego
leak that shows a Lego figurine
underneath it the name Marvel which is
another confirmation that Jude Lobb will
be playing Marvel and if that wasn't
enough Fandango tweeted out an exclusive
photo this morning as you can see here
the photo has algin Apsaras Soto who is
playing at last brie Larson who of
course is playing Captain Marvel and
Jude Law but what the tweet said
actually is what gives it away
Fandango tweeted Captain Marvel and
marvel hits theaters March 2019 which is
another confirmation that Jude Law will
be playing Marvel a lot of people
thought that he was actually going to be
playing Yan Robb who is a villain to
Captain Marvel and a villain to Marvel
some people think that he could still
possibly be playing both characters one
is a good persona which is marvel and
one is a bad persona which would be on
raagh that would certainly add a twist
to the movie but I do not think it's
likely however another twist that could
end up in the movie is that a net
benning's character actually turns out
to be on rock we don't know who her care
yet Marvel has done a pretty good job at
keeping that a secret but now that we
know that Jude Law
is playing Marvel she could be playing
Yan rod in the comics both characters
Marvel and Yan raag are critical in the
story of Carol Danvers getting her
powers so it would make sense that they
would both be in the movie but it looks
like we're going to have to wait a
little bit longer to find out who's
playing Yan Rob so what do you think
about these new Captain Marvel leaks and
do you think Jude Law could be playing
both Marvel and Yan rod or do you think
that Annette Bening could possibly be
playing Yan rod let me know your
thoughts and theories in the comments
down below and don't forget to subscribe
comment and like the video so you can
enter the Infinity Gauntlet giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to Captain Marvel and Avengers endgame
as always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]